all right welcome everybody welcome to
the stream we have another democratic
debate happening tonight and it is
happening at the top of the hour there
are all sorts of free event things going
on and we are going to be doing the
actual debate we will do just over on
Twitch but I'll be here until the top of
the hour on YouTube answering questions
and doing other things and this time
we're actually doing the pre-show on
both YouTube and twitch and then I
believe that what I can do is at the top
of the hour just stop the YouTube feed
and then restart it right after the
debate for the post show and I think I
can do it all without interrupting
anything over on Twitch so that's the
plan at least that's what I'm going to
try it is going to be a very interesting
debate tonight because we still do not
actually have 100% results from Iowa in
a sense we do although technically they
are sort of calling it 99% reporting
because it's completely whacked out and
there have been irregularities
incompetence technical issues and all
sorts of different stuff so first and
foremost one of the immediate questions
tonight will be whether there are
questions about the Iowa caucus process
and results whether Bernie Sanders and
Pete Budaj edge go after each other and
we've seen just in the last 24 hours
way more willing list willingness that
is from Bernie Sanders to go after Pete
even than we've seen from Bernie Sanders
to go after Joe Biden throughout this
entire campaign so that will be very
interesting will Joe Biden after a
disastrous performance in Iowa remember
Joe Biden was polling second right
behind Bernie and ended up coming in
fourth as of right now and not even
ahead of Amy Klobuchar by that much we
are going to see whether Joe Biden comes
out with more energy or aggression or
whatever the case may be I don't think
that it was a strategy that Joe Biden
was not high energy or aggressive I
think Joe Joe Biden is just seeming very
very tired so I don't know that it's
something that's even up to him
necessarily so it's going to be very
interesting debate and then we have on
Tuesday the New Hampshire primary and
very quickly we are going to get more
numbers
in terms of Delegates and looking there
there is now III don't like it I'm just
reporting it to you there is a Buddha
judge Serge you can see the yellow line
here Pete Buddha judge who had been
slowly climbing and then since the day
of the Iowa caucuses a increasing still
not a head but increasing in our sorry
no that's Michael Bloomberg what am I
even pointing to I'm pointing to the
wrong line people who judges over here
but people do judge polling very well in
some of the recent no this is not even
this is the wrong poll what I knew it
looked wrong okay this is New Hampshire
there it is
Buddha judge is the Purple Line I was
looking at the wrong thing those were
national polls here is Buddha jej where
you see that in the days following the
February 3rd Iowa poll going up and
almost tying Bernie Sanders and of
course this is immediately getting
people fired up about this is the DNC
establishments new darling
the DNC establishment realizes that Joe
Biden maybe can't hack it and the new
strategy is to get behind Pete Budaj
edge if and until Michael Bloomberg
becomes viable and then maybe we will
see the establishment switch to
Bloomberg here's what is really
important to understand about the stop
Bernie movement oh and I'm realizing I'm
not quite set up for a stream here and
my my equipment that I have in front of
me the thing about the stop Bernie
movement is Bernie needs to win to be
the nominee the establishment merely
needs to deny Bernie the nomination on
the first round by the first round of
voting at the DNC to allow the
super-delegates in to give it to
somebody else so it's an asymmetrical
battle in a sense because if your goal
is merely prevent Bernie from being sort
of like in football you can run a
prevent defense which will restrict the
offense and depend you would only do
that depending on what your objective is
right if you want if you're okay
allowing a certain amount of yardage but
you don't want to give up a touchdown
for example there's a type of football
defense that you can run in the same way
the DNC doesn't need to get a winner
across the finish line
before the convention or even at the
first vote they just need to deny that
to Bernie and then super-delegates can
help them a crown whoever it is they
want a crown on the second ballot and of
course they're also looking at changing
the rules to allow super-delegates back
in on the first ballot at the DNC
if you don't know what I'm talking about
don't even worry about it because we are
going to have plenty more time to talk
about that in the future I will take
super chats and messages via twitch
subscriptions until the top of the hour
when the debate starts let me say thank
you to economy 12 for subscribing with
twitch Prime let me say thank you to
Rhapsody's on graz for subscribing with
twitch prime would the message keep up
the good fight pakman Darth Bane has
subscribed for six months in a row with
the message ye with many many E's and
then Asghar has subscribed with twitch
Prime if you are a twitch user I will be
on ROG Royale I believe it's called
tomorrow at 4 p.m. Eastern Time and that
may be something that some of my twitch
followers are interested in let's go
over to YouTube where super chats are
starting to trickle in I wouldn't call
it pour in but they are trickling and a
hound dog says I definitely expect some
fireworks tonight go Bernie
a herd core val says in your honest
opinion how badly would Pete go against
Trump I can think of so many insults and
positions that Trump can go after I do
not believe that mayor Pete Budaj edge
would do well against Donald Trump I'm
not talking about the voting I know that
we have hypothetical voting now that we
can look at I'm not talking about that
that will change I think that the the
public facing campaign of Trump versus
Budaj edge would not go particularly
well for Budaj edge max says how can we
combat the DNC and media in all so for
the next nine months in the primary and
in the final election the way to do
anything is to overwhelm the vote so
drastically that foul play and
shenanigans can't be the decide
factor I've been saying that that's the
reality for November and it's
essentially the same reality for the for
the Democratic primary we do have a hype
train happening on Twitch and I
appreciate everybody who's participating
I want to say thanks to Eric red 25 for
the subscription and Sam Zeldin
a c0 five-10 has gifted 5 subscriptions
c-note subscribed and says how soon do
you think establishment Democrats will
have to all line up behind a candidate
to pose the substantial threat to Bernie
so I was actually just talking about
this they only have to deny Bernie the
nomination and you can do that without
aligning behind one establishment
candidate and we're going to talk about
that quite a bit on on Monday
thanks to JP Dunphy for the YouTube
channel membership I appreciate that as
many of you know we reached and
surpassed 800,000 subscribers a few days
ago live on stream and we now are at a
closing in on eight hundred and two
thousand incredibly enough let's also
look at some other messages coming in
via super chad milan davit cove says how
do you feel about bernie going after
pete more directly i tend to appreciate
it it's just time i mean that's that's
the unfortunate reality that it's it's
what has to happen now all candidates
are going to have to take each other on
more directly now that we're at this
point in the campaign and i expect to
see some of it tonight Shaun King says
Deepak what are your top three favorite
books of all time oh I don't know I mean
I've read you know hundreds and hundreds
of books it's so hard to say you'd have
to give me a genre maybe Rock Lee says
is yang saying he might pardon Trump
disqualifying I didn't see him say that
so I wouldn't be able to comment on that
because I haven't I haven't seen it let
me let you know that we do have a target
tonight of fifty web site members we
absolutely destroyed it I think we got
280 during the Iowa caucus or State of
the Union stream last week I think it
was we have a modest target of 50 we do
still have my birthday coupon code
available my birthday was last Sunday
the coupon code 36 today
saves you 60% isn't that insane
yeah it saves you 60% when you go to
join pakman.com and use that coupon code
new members will literally move the bar
this bar that dark blue will start to
fill up as people sign up and I will
thank you and I will sing your praises
and I will just talk about what an
incredible person you are
case in point let me give you an example
of that David Ross man David Ross man
just signed up David Ross man is new
member number one out of 50 today and
David Ross man is just an incredible
person who I would be privileged to be
stuck on a lifeboat with let me put it
that way
okay if you're just joining us we are
waiting for the debate at the top of the
hour there is all sorts of discussion
with chris Christie and others happening
right now because of copyright concerns
at the top of the hour when the debate
starts we will go over to twitch only
okay we will switch over to twitch only
at the top of the hour I hope you'll
follow us over there twitch TV slash
David Pakman we are already live there
make sure to follow us there the debate
itself will be on twitch and then we'll
be back on YouTube for the post debate
show JP Dunphy says do you think the
electoral college will be abolished to
make one vote worth one vote again it
would be very difficult to abolish the
electoral college but what could be
possible is the national popular vote
interstate compact check out my videos
on that over on Twitch we are trying to
complete the level 4 hype train we only
have 50 seconds and it's not looking
good
but this would be a good time to either
grab a subscription twitch prime regular
whatever trade Baer did that and
subscribe for one month at tier one
we're down to our last 34 seconds right
now and we did it some OS guard just
gave out five Tier one community
subscriptions and we have now completed
level four of the hype train people on
YouTube are disoriented they look
punch-drunk because they don't know what
hype train what the hell is going on
you'll see very quickly
now what it is when we switch over to
twitch at the top of the hour let me
also say thanks to mass his story a
podcast for subscribing night traveler
stun ever and t-mac t-mac also thank you
very much I do appreciate that and I
also want to say thank you to Alex har
bolt
Alex har bolt is new member number two
of the evening at join pakman.com other
questions that are coming in Madison
2019 says how do we fix the primaries I
have a video that published it must have
been a half-hour ago let me see here I
have a video that published very
recently called Iowa can no longer be
first to vote and I outline in that
video exactly how to fix the primaries
Madison Lord and Master 14 says hello
everyone ah see here I'm hoping Bernie
does well tonight I do agree that he
needs to go after Pete tonight and if
he's up to it the DNC I would be shocked
if Bernie goes after the DNC tonight I
would be I would be absolutely shocked
let me say thank you to Kay hearts for
subscribing on Twitch free will 87 thank
you for the sub imperfect 1091 thank you
and herm pees with the message Pakman
has the best hair yeah it's it's under
control today it might explode if if
Bernie goes after the DNC let's see here
Rock Lee says Liz can't keep up with
Bernie's fundraising for long
yeah let's actually look at the polling
I actually believe that it's over for
Elizabeth Warren I have a long time sort
of colleague acquaintance who's been
working with Elizabeth Warren for a long
time look at where she peaked here
almost tying Joe Biden back in October
and it has been a straight decline now
admittedly it's been basically level
since the end of November but Liz just
has no momentum and she ended up sort of
a distant third in Iowa in New Hampshire
Elizabeth Warren now is a distant third
in Nevada Elizabeth Warren is again
polling a distant third
as you can see here in South Carolina
Elizabeth Warren is where is Warren
Warren is polling fourth and it's it's
not Lucas just out of curiosity where is
Warren in California okay in California
she's still competing she's actually
tied statistically for second place with
uh with Joe Biden I would be shocked at
this point is if Elizabeth Warren's
campaign makes a comeback I just don't
see it it just seems extraordinarily
unlikely the momentum has deflated let
me say thanks to a few other people for
their twitch subscriptions mint cheese
has subscribed Chris G little or Chris
little has subscribed and is a 7-month
subscriber thanks for the bits too in
now II and veggie-boy Johnny zo6
has subscribed with prime and Sharon
Stone has subscribed with twitch prime
thank you very much I appreciate that
Sean Walker sends a super chap Daniel
Krieger says I appreciate you so much
Daniel I appreciate you Daniel is like a
david pakman show all-star daniel
regularly super chats I'm pretty sure
Daniel is a website member at join
pakman.com and it's just an all-around
good guy so I appreciate that you're
just joining us we are about 15 minutes
away from the democratic debate in
advance of the New Hampshire primary we
are going to at the top of the hour for
copyright purposes with peace and love
we will go over to twitch that's where
the debate analysis live will be and
then will restart on youtube for the
post show twitch.tv slash david pakman
that is it seems safer for these debates
so we will be we will be over there but
until then I will keep answering
questions via super chat and twitch
messages I will also thank new members I
want to say thank you to Rebecca
Belcher Rebecca Belcher is new member
number three on my website the game is
we want to fill this entire bar up and
every time someone signs up at join
pakman.com the bar fills up Lou
Raun filling it up a little bit more
Luke Brown as new member number five of
the evening thanks Luke I really
appreciate that
casual Thursday says via oh no my uh my
chest trophy is actually blocking my
view of the super chat let me see if I
can get this out of the way hold on this
was one of the gag birthday gifts that
the david pakman show team sent me it's
a chess trophy and it says david pakman
david pakman show chess champion I guess
it's kind of hard to see so far there's
only been one game adjudicating that I
defeated producer Pat who never plays
chess in a game of chess before the New
Year before vacation and I'm the de
facto chess champion but we will be
having a big David Pakman show chess
tournament soon and then somebody else
may may get their own their own trophy
okay so casual Thursday says we are on a
level 69 hypetrain straight to
authoritarianism how would you rate the
Bernie hypetrain
to the Trump hypetrain David based on
clear numerical levels of course I have
no idea what you're talking about but
you seem fired up and I'm fired up for
tonight's debate as well Matt Stone says
what other tricks does the DNC have up
its sleeve over the next few months well
remember the DNC is waging asymmetrical
warfare the DNC needs only to deny
Bernie the candidates the nomination
before the first vote at the DNC they
don't need anyone to win they just need
to run interference all right so that is
going to inform their tactics and
strategy tony is oh says I've been told
that Trump could conceivably run in 2024
because impeachment not have nullified
his term despite what the Constitution
says is that possible no that is not
possible that is not possible
Gordy I mean listen he can try it but
it's not it would be illegal Gordie Howe
says where is Lewis Oh Lewis Lewis left
the show four years ago he's not been
around for four years
Justin Gurley says should Bernie mess
Bernie's messages on the health care
debate go after the upper management
where the money goes and explained the
only way insurance companies make money
is to deny coverage of people that's not
totally right because there are rule
about the percentage of premiums that
have to be paid back out in benefits
otherwise the insurance companies owe
subscribers our refund but we're in the
weeds and I don't know that that's
actually the best thing for Bernie to
talk about it so it's a little bit
confused let me say thanks over on
twitch to dart 'union
for the twits Prime subscription stun
ever has gifted a subscription mister
dude man 3000 has subscribed with Prime
and Rick rich Obie has subscribed with
prime if you're joining us for copyright
reasons at the top of the hour when the
debate starts we will stream the debate
live only on Twitch ok twitch.tv slash
david pakman so I hope you find folks
will follow me over there we'll have
analysis during the debate if we don't
get shut down and then as soon as the
debates over we'll kick back on the
YouTube stream and come back over here a
question for the yang gangers and the
Tulsi supporters in my audience
when will they rock it and take over
these these the race because I know that
there are a lot of people in my audience
who feel strongly that it's going to
happen and it's just a question of when
so my question is when when is it that
that is going to happen I want to know
let me say thanks to Conor Cahoon who is
new member number five tonight at join
pakman.com I also want to say thanks to
Oliver star whose new member number six
at join pakman.com I appreciate that
Edson Garcia says now that Warren
doesn't have a shot at the nomination
will you endorse Bernie
endure I don't I'm not endorsing anyone
but I think it's pretty clear at this
point there are two candidates Bernie
and Biden who do you think I'm voting
for right I mean it said it's down to
the two of them and I am NOT a Biden guy
the tad tad ger says David if I give a
big super check can you donate it to
Bernie I'm Irish and I want to influence
foreign elections that would be illegal
and I would never do anything like that
Jimmy big nuts says dick Huck you seen
538 s latest projection I have not I
have not but I will
maybe someone can tell me tell me what
it what it is Sean Walker says dude give
a shout-out to system76 please alright
Bernie's bro Bernie wins delegate count
once errors are fixed yeah well I have
no idea I anticipated that in the end
the delegate count would be within 1 for
the two leading candidates that's where
it is right now maybe it'll flip I'm not
sure if you look down here you do see
that Bernie won the final popular vote
by about twenty six fifty but is shy on
the SD ease it's a terrible system of
course and we'll see ultimately what the
numbers are okay let me say thanks to
Akeem Pharaoh Akeem Pharoah is new
member number seven today at join
pakman.com so it's something very cool
happened today I found out about two
celebrities who are not publicly
political okay public figures let me
call them instead of celebrities that
are big David Pakman show fans I'm not
going to say who they are because I
don't even know if their politics are
known but it was extremely exciting
extremely exciting and maybe someday the
story will be told I think it would be a
very very interesting story to a lot of
people in the audience let me say thank
you to Rattlehead mega for subscribing
with twitch prime remember that at the
top of the hour we are going to be doing
the live debate stream only on Twitch
for copyright reasons wink-wink
nudge-nudge people know what's going on
I think and then we'll come back for a
post debate show back on to YouTube and
we'll hopefully keep the entire thing
going on Twitch the entire time let's
see here Captain Crunch says you happen
to know how many of those delegates were
a coin toss win for Budaj edge in Iowa
saw a video where he won at least one
that way on Twitter I don't know I don't
know the answer to that but any system
that uses coin flips is not a system I
think is a good system Matt Stone says
if Bernie wins the most delegates but
gets the
I to the nomination by super-delegates
what do you think would happen I think
there would be outrage and then I think
that he still wouldn't get the
nomination because that's just the way
these things kind of go Nick theodoro is
new member number eight at join
pakman.com thanks Nick I appreciate that
for people wondering about these
memberships Sunday was my birthday and
we set up a coupon code 36 today it's a
60% discount and it'll apply to any
membership at join pakman.com and you
save 60% and your name pops up and the
blue bar gets filled in and I thank you
and everybody's just so happy when it
happened so I recommend it let's see
here Bob to to five-ish says sad the
Republican Party nominated Trump
thoroughly in 2016
well the DNC sabotages or sabotages as
William Shatner says Bernie in any way
I'm convinced that if he loses its DNC I
will only vote Bernie well that's a
problem I understand the frustration but
that that we know we want to get Trump
out that getting Trump out has to be a
top top priority Kowalski from Nebraska
have some subsidized corn money I'm a
farmer by the way yeah Kowalski called
into my show the other day assuming it's
the same Kowalski and afterwards I got a
bunch of emails from people saying that
Kowalski is a regular Sam cedar caller
and that he was being in that it was a
sign of infidelity to Sam cedar that
Kowalski called into my show and people
were all worked up about it I don't know
if any of its true to be totally honest
Hoosier daddy says responds to the
saying nothing that requires the labor
of others is a basic human right in
regards to health care I get stuck when
people bring this up a lot nothing that
requires the labor of others as a basic
human right well you don't have to
defend it if they can't justify it why
who says that what why why nothing that
requires the label labor of others is a
basic human right make make the person
who makes that assertion actually defend
it because I don't know that it's
obvious to me that
that's the that's that's the the case
let me say thank you to Ray ello for
subscribing with twitch Prime we are now
at 871 twitch subscribers and I would
love to get to a thousand twitch
subscribers today we will be doing the
livestream we're doing the pre-show on
YouTube and twitch some of you know the
trouble we've had streaming debates on
YouTube we've had some trouble on twitch
as well but less so at the top of the
hour we will kind of like pinch off the
YouTube stream as it effectively will be
and be only over on Twitch but then if
things go well I will be back for the
post show on YouTube you can find us on
twitch at twitch.tv slash david pakman
make sure you're following us there let
me say thank you to Kim dump Trump
Wallace Kim dump Trump Wallace is new
member number 9 of the evening at join
pakman.com jbp VFL says hi dave had been
following for several months after Tim
Poole recommended your channel in order
to get a good left-leaning channel so as
to not only hear one side that's
interesting because Tim Poole claims to
also be on the left so it's interesting
you had to come to me to get the other
side that's interesting would love to
see you and Tim do a collaboration from
time to time Tim and I have something
cooking okay and it doesn't matter what
you think of Tim we have something
cooking that's exciting but I cannot
announce it today
heads ur head says happy late birthday
pack looking 26 at 36 is magic thank you
I appreciate that
let me also say thank you to genial shot
for the twitch subscription chief Mr
Freeze and she hun she hun okay on that
note I am now going to shut down the
YouTube stream please join us for
continuing coverage hopefully
uninterrupted coverage over on twitch
twitch TV slash David Pakman
I'm already live on Twitch join me there
right now the debate